[Music]  you ready for this  I've never been more ready for anything  in my whole life you know I love you no  matter what happens  [Music]  housing your mind and that's it you owe  me all the time  [Music]  there's something I got to tell you we  are drinking to new life Tish gonna have  funnies baby I hope it's a boy come on  over here daughter you're a good girl  I'm proud of you don't you ever forget  it  and who's gonna be responsible for this  maybe the father and the mother when I  hold you in my arms I got old our baby a  mouse  well fine do it that child was born of  sin a child it's your grandchild what  difference does it make how it gets here  and bow your head sister  we've known Bonnie father's life  [Music]  he's about to pay for something he  didn't do these are children and we  gotta set them free  remember love is what brought you here  [Music]  and if you trust in love this far  [Music]  just it all the way just remember beyond  song  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]